la guerra en ucrania ha causado
conmoción mundial y son muchos los que
quieren ayudar en londres reino unido un
centro de ayuda para los refugiados
ucranianos se ha visto desbordado por
los voluntarios y las donaciones
viendo la televisión y las noticias y
viendo las mujeres con niños con lo
puesto y con mochilas pequeñas el
sentido común dice que salieron de sus
casas sin nada no tienen absolutamente
nada lo necesitan todo tenemos que
ayudarles el proyecto haarp ganó una
iniciativa que turquía también ha puesto
en marcha con la recolección de
alimentos medicamentos y otros productos
básicos desde la embajada ucraniana en
ankara
burga la razón por la que ayuda es
porque viven por seis años en ucrania
bebía agua y con mi pan de ese país me
casé con una mujer de allí y tenemos un
hijo es como mi hogar de reuma pero los
países no se preparan únicamente para
mandar ayudas algunos se alistan para
recibir a los desplazados en las mejores
condiciones posibles como hungría donde
ofrecen desde comida a alojamiento
gratuito para
algunos números incluso van a la
frontera para recibir a los que llegan
no me importa la política ni las
organizaciones solo me importan los
seres humanos que están en la miseria y
alguien tiene que estar con ellos para
darles un abrazo comida consejos y
esperanzas en su hotel natural es un
apoyo destinado a los más de medio
millón de ucranianos que ya han
abandonado el país pero también a los
que aún permanecen en ucrania